Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
Game Of Thrones did some very unexpected but
very big things.
Bran came back into the story in a big way
and it seems like they’re changing some
of the plot in the north so that the larger
story this season is a little more concise
without dropping secondary characters as much
as it did last year.
In addition, round 4 of the giveaway starts
now.
If you’re finding me for the first time
just as a way to say thank you to all you
guys for being so awesome I’m selecting
one random subscriber from the comments to
give a $20 amazon gift card too.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment.
I’ll announce the winner in my Q&A video
tomorrow night.
I was so happy with everything that happened
this week, let’s start with WTF moments
and then I’ll do my review.
Careful for Spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Number 5 - Littlefinger explains the Purple
Wedding
We have to give Sansa some credit, she figured
out most of what happened.
But Littlefinger continues to creep the hell
out of us in the best possible way.
He wants everything, but what does that even
mean.
Does he want to sit on the Iron Throne?
Or does he just want power over everyone.
It think he just wants to be a god on earth.
Just have the entire world serve his whims.
Like you would think of characters in a tabletop
game.
I think he just enjoys playing the game so
to speak.
As opposed to Varys who actually seemed like
he had a noble purpose in mind, despite being
pretty awful himself.
Other big takeaways from this, they’re heading
to the Eyrie, Littlefinger is marrying Sansa’s
crazy aunt and she’s just going to chill
out with them.
And probably try to avoid Littlefinger in
the hallways.
Number 4 - Daenerys takes Meereen
It’s not really a seige so much as an infiltration,
but this was really similar to the way it
happened in the books.
There was never a big battle, Daenerys was
let in by the slaves after they turned on
their masters.
And her family just doubled in size.
Remember, Meereen is as big as Astapor and
Yunkai combined.
I loved Grey Worm in this episode, it was
like they let Daario be a badass last week,
so now it was Grey Worm’s turn to have his
hero moment.
I love how brainwashed he is, he doesn’t
care about returning to his home on the summer
aisles, he just wants to kill the masters.
Daenerys nailing them up was pretty hardcore,
but I like how much she craves the idea of
justice and revengee.
It really did feel more like revenge when
you saw that look on her face.
Hands down though, my favorite part was the
big shot of the city that opens up to reveal
the Targaryen flag on top of the pyramid.
It’s like she’s slowly reclaiming the
honor and glory of house Targaryen.
Number 3 - Burn Gorman Is the True King Of
The North
I feel like Burn Gorman really won this episode
as an actor.
Did anyone else get a Shakespeare Hamlet vibe
when he was talking to the skull.
I flipped a little when they revealed it was
Lord Mormont’s skull.
This was one of the huge changes from the
books.
Burn Gorman’s character Karl is in the book,
but the show is doing something different
with the Craster storyline.
Personally I don’t mind, because it gives
them the opportunity to bring Bran back into
the story in a big way and I know a lot of
you guys were saying you thought that was
the weakest part of the plot so far.
Bran just wasn’t really integral to the
story.
I actually thought that Bran was going to
warg into Burn Gorman and make him kill himself.
Because this isn’t in the books I’m wondering
if they’re going to actually do something
like that.
Or if Jon will make it there and rescue them.
Number 2 - Jaime Gives Brienne Oathkeeper
This was one of the big moments in the books
and I love the small changes they made on
the show.
In the books, the implied ‘ship between
Jaime and Brienne isn’t really as explicit
as it is on the show.
And you didn’t get to visually see the emotion
exploding all over Brienne’s face when Jaime
gives her the sword and the armor.
It’s almost like she’s so overcome with
feels that all she can think of is honor and
duty.
I wouldn’t mind if HBO just wanted to spin
off a show about the two of them.
I could watch their scenes all day.
That Podrick reveal was so much fun too.
Just a perfect way to cut that intense scene
with comedy.
In the books Podrick also travels with her,
but instead of Tyrion and Jaime sending him
with her officially, he just kind of stalked
her from a distance until she accepted his
assistance.
And my Number 1 WTF Moment - The Court of
the White Walkers
All I could think about as the white walker
rode into that landscape was of the Witch
King’s castle from Lord of The Rings.
It looked like the Superman’s Fortress of
Solitude if it were designed by the Witch
King of Angmar.
I saw a lot of people complaining on twitter
that this was a Winds of Winter Spoiler.
I don’t know if that’s true, but it’s
kind of implied that we’re going to see
a lot more white walker centric stuff then.
Because it’s the next to last book.
The white walker that actually performed the
transformation on that baby looked like it
was a white walker that just held more rank
than the one that brought the baby.
It kind of looked like he had a crown on his
head but I couldn’t tell.
As if they have their own hierarchy.
They perform their own kinds of necromancy
and magic.
But the books haven’t really explained how
it works in great detail.
So this scene was really exciting for book
readers and people that just watch the show.
In fact, I’ll go on to say that I liked
this scene just as much as I liked Joffrey’s
Death.
And somehow, I have a feeling the show is
going to do something to top it before the
season is over.
But the big takeaway is that white walkers
aren’t born and they’re not undead like
the wights.
They’re turned as babies and raised.
So much more we could talk about, but let
me know what your favorite WTF moment was.
Court of the White Walkers, Burn Gorman just
being awesome or something else?
Here’s a couple really important plot points
that we need to pay attention to but didn’t
beat out my top 5 moments.
Janos Slynt and Aliser Thorne were plotting
to get rid of Jon Snow by just letting him
get himself killed at Crasters.
Keep you eyes on them.
Locke mysteriously appeared at the Night’s
Watch and seems like he’s tailing Jon Snow
everywhere he goes.
He’s just waiting for the right moment to
kill him for Roose Bolton to secure their
claim on the North.
The Kingslayer brothers are finally bonding
and I totally love it.
The hatred they’re both getting from the
Cersei and Tywin is really bringing them together.
It looks like the real reason the aged Tommen
up and recasted the actor was so that they
could do these types of sexy Margaery scenes.
How funny was it that the Queen of Thrones
revealed she killed Joffrey AND humped her
husband so hard he couldn’t walk the night
before they got married.
I used to think of her as being a female Tywin,
but she just got way more badass than Tywin.
I was bummed they recast Tommen just for hump
day, but they totally gave us Ser Pounce,
who was a really fun part of the books.
So it’s like they take something away with
one hand and give us a treat with the other.
And that reminds me, I heard at least three
separate characters make jokes about losing
their right hand.
It’s almost like the writers are trolling
Jaime.
One of my favorite lines was when she said
“Marrying a Targaryen was all the rage back
then.”
Overall the episode was amazing, I gave it
a solid A for use of Burn Gorman and White
Walkers.
I think they did a good job of addressing
issues with Bran’s character from last season
by bringing him back into the story around
the Wall.
And I love that they’re making show Sansa
seem a lot smarter than book Sansa.
So all in all, even though they did make some
big changes from the books.
Namely the mega white walker scene.
I totally love what they did.
There were several really breathtaking scenes
that reminded me of last season when Jon Snow
climbed the Wall and they showed the big wide
shot of the south side of the wall.
Like Daenerys on top of the pyramid.
There was also a really cool night shot of
the city when they were breaking in.
And that Lord of the Rings white walker mountain.
I think they’re able to spend money on that
kind of stuff because they don’t put dragons
in every episode.
So if you ever wondered why they aren’t
around all the time, it’s because they want
to do big CG landscapes.
Let me know if you have any other thoughts
about the big changes they made or the extra
white walker scenes they included.
And remember, my Q&A will post tomorrow.
So be sure to subscribe to get it.
And leave me suggestions for future bonus
videos.
Maybe a white walker one given what we just
saw.
Right now click here for that Q&A video, I’ll
add the annotation as soon as I post the video
and click here to learn all about the Bloodraven.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!